hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masid a daa center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even more
[Music]
how are you guys doing I was scrolling
on Twitter a little bit cuz I was a bit
bored and I was dumbfounded bedazzled or
otherwise floxed
byx is FL by this little sorry excuse of
a weasel of a specimen of a human being
that has come up on my feet and I don't
know why he keeps coming up on my feet
um actually calling to what seems to be
violence I mean let's take a look at the
video come back and respond in kind this
is something I've written about but it's
so important that I'm making this quick
short video as well we have to stop
trying to educate anti-semites and we
have to hurt them
instead Decades of Education
has not worked it has not worked it is
the worst it has ever been it has
factually failed this is the most
dangerous time to be a Jew in our living
lifetime education has failed to stop
those who are
anti-semitic stop trying to cure them
stop trying to heal them stop thinking
it's your job to be some kind of nurse
or therapist for them or Savior for
their [__] hatred stop trying to heal
anti-semites and hurt them that will
make them stop they will not stop
because of intellectual ideas they will
not stop because you magically put
butterflies and unicorns and fairies and
love into their heart they will stop out
of fear because they know they will get
hurt they will stop because it is
unpleasant
to get hurt so what do you think of this
bro I think it's not I think I think I
think it's not fair for him to talk
about hurting people looking like that
cuz it doesn't do justice to the cause
because I don't think he's got the
facilities for that ex I don't think you
have the facilities for that big man he
doesn't have the
capabilities that's why laughing the
moment he started speaking with a
squeaky voice and and and the way he
look I don't you can't you have to do
justice to the words you say you get it
if you have a little child and come and
say I'm going to do this you don't
really take him seriously so I yeah and
it's very ironic coming from him Subhan
Allah cuz the thing is he's talking
about anti-sites but obviously his
definition of that is anyone who's
against Israel as anyone who objective
we don't know what his definition of
that is but from his I've checked his uh
feed this this particular individual and
and seen how anti- Palestine anti-islam
this guy is disgusting bro so I would
not even want to know what his
definition of
anti-semitism is but imagine not saying
something similar to oh my gosh oh my
gosh can you imag imagine that bro can
you imagine us telling that we need to
start hurting people can you imagine we
start hurting enough of us talking I
mean you can't make this stuff up man
absolutely just hypocrisy and and the
the hatred is coming from you this is
the ironic part you know it's it's you
are the one that's transgressing and you
are the one that's crying and you've
never seen something like this in
history you know many people have talked
about it even um uh what's that guy's
name the comedian who was on the
Egyptian B mus yeah he even said that
he's like I'm he just like with the
psychopath you know he yeah yeah it
cause you damage Etc and then they they
blame you they Gest like you you know
it's it's unbelievable that what you
what they have done in Gaza and on top
of that they are now saying oh it's time
for us to do what you're already doing
that he's talking about educating what
was that education and what's what's
violence you know it's just it's just
showing their reality and yeah I mean I
think the whole world has really seen
like there's not much really to say it's
just they just need to carry and talking
like I said before just carry and
talking because you're exposing yourself
uh and you guys are really about you
know the whole world has seen your mask
drop and now they're in a desperate
situation it really shows them because
the whole public perception has changed
in America towards these uh you know
towards um um these zionists you know
people are saying America First they've
seen it you know he supporting them
funding them Etc and look what look what
they're doing look at the Tres that
they've committed so the public
perception is changing and and they've
done it tosel they have done it himself
Israel has become the most um unsafe
places for for for the Jews and and they
them have caused this after all these
years of uh them building up their
country there's I and going to stop
those intellectual Rockets no but look
at the country now no one's going to
want to go there for tourism no way
people leaving bro they leav in the
country yeah absolutely they in the
thousands bro they leaving yeah and they
should and with that I will conclude
because there's not much to say about
this but I want to bring this to people
look at this guy I
mean it's just the demeanor it's just a
so weak the way the guy looks
that it's not even worthy of response
it's just good to have like a a laugh a
laugh about
[Laughter]
it the prophet Muhammad
s told us that when the son of Adam dies
all of his Good Deeds are interrupted
they are finished except for three
things a continuous charity and a
beneficial knowledge and also a a
righteous offspring that makes Dua for
him your brothers and sisters in Islam
net from Norway are establishing a Masid
a DA Center and fulfilling a great
portion of this Hadith on your behalf
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do whenever someone
prays there whenever someone gives
shahada in the Masjid whenever someone
learn something in the Masid yes that
will be something that you will have on
your scale so give generously and Allah
will give you even more